سامر ساعيد السؤال البنتاجون يقول بان هذه
العمليات والهجمات ضد مواقع في سوريا
والعراق ستستمر في الايام المقبله كيف
تقارب السلطات العراقيه هذه الهجمات
كلام السلطات هنا يبدو موحدا كما جرت
العاده جلال استنكار اعتداء على السياده
العراقيه خطوات يمكن ان تتخذها وزاره
الخارجيه العراقيه ايضا بالتشاور مع
الحكومه تجاه الوجود العسكري الاجنبي على
راسه الوجود العسكري الامريكي في البلاد
وهذا ما حصل اليوم من مذكره احتجاج وصفها
مسؤولو بانها شديده اللهجه سلمت الى
القائم بالاعمال في السفاره الامريكيه في
الداخل العراقي ولكن الحديث الان يمكن ان
يتحول الى الضفه الاخرى هنا في الداخل
العراقي هم فصائل المقاومه الاسلام في
العراق وكيف سيكون ردهم يمكن من خلال هذا
الرد ان ترسم ملامح هذه العمليات
الامريكيه او الرد من الفصائل
العراقيه هنا المنضوي في المقاومه
الاسلاميه في العراق التي على ما يبدو
تستمر في عملياتها قبل قليل كما اسلفت
هناك استهداف جديد في الداخل السوري تبنته
المقاومه الاسلاميه العراقيه في قاعده
خراب جير التي تضم قوات امريكيه هذه
الفصائل توعدت باستمرار هذه المواجهات
وقالت على الرغم من ان فصيل بارز مثل
كتائب حزب الله العراقيه اوقف عملياته علق
عملياته لدفع الحرج عن الحكومه العراقيه
التي تدخل في مفاوضات مع الولايات المتحده
لانسحاب تدريجي لقوات التحالف الدولي من
البلاد كما تقول السلطات العراقيه الا ان
الرد الامريكي
جاء وتوعد
بالاستمرار في قصف مواقع في الداخل
العراقي التخوف ايضا هنا من ان هذه
الهجمات الامريكيه الضربات المستقبليه قد
تطال مواقع اكثر عمقا في الداخل العراقي
ولا تكتفي بمواقع قريبه على الحدود
العراقيه السوريه في اقصى
غرب البلاد على هذا الاساس يمكن للمقاومه
العراقيه كما ت يقول ان تستمر بهجمات حتى
ان توقف او تخرج القوات الاجنبيه من كامل
الاراضي العراقيه وايضا ان يتوقف العدوان
وتتوقف الحرب على قطاع غزه هنا في العراق
لا يفصلون كما في الولايات المتحده بين
الحرب على غزه
والهجمات على القواعد الامريكيه التي
تنفذها فصائل المقاومه هي محاوله من هذه
الفصائل للضغط على الولايات المتحده
بالتالي ل
الضغط على اسرائيل بدورها لان توقف الحرب
احدى شروط الفصائل العراقيه في المقاومه
الاسلاميه العراقيه ان تتوقف الحرب على
غزه فهي استانفت هذه الضربات بعد اكثر من
سنه من توقفها استؤنفت بعد الحرب على قطاع
غزه في السابع او بعد احداث السابع من
اكتوبر طيب الماضي لذلك لا يفرق العراقيون
على مستوى الفصائل بين الحرب على قطاع غزه
وما يجري في الداخل العراقي وايضا السوري
طيب قبل ان تحول الى محمد العلمي اشير الى
هذه التطورات القياده الوسطى الامريكيه
تقول بان المسيرات كانت في المناطق التي
يسيطر عليها الحوثيون في اليمن وبان
المسيرات شكلت تهديدا للسفن وبحريه
الامريكيه في المنطقه ودمرنا دفاعا عن
النفس وتقول القياده الوسطى الامريكيه
اجراءاتها ستحمي حريه الملاحه في البحر
الاحمر وستجعل المياه الدوليه اكثر امانا
من هذا المنطلق محمد العلمي كيف ستوا ازي
واشنطن بين ردها سواء كان على الحوثيين او
على جماعات تعتبرها مدعومه من ايران في
سوريا والعراق وبينما تقول بعدم التصعيد
في
المنطقه هذا اكبر تحدي يواجهه الرئيس
بايدن جلال سواء على المستوى الاستراتيجي
او حتى على المستوى والداخلي السياسي
واكيد انه يراقب الان من بيته العائل في
ولايه ديلاوير ردود الفعل المحتمله وربما
المرتقبه امريكيا من المنطقه حتى
تصميم واختيار الاهداف واذاعه هذه
الاهداف تقريبا بضعه ايام قبل
تنفيذها كان الهدف منه على ما يبدو هو عدم
جر ايران الى حرب عدم جر الولايات المتحده
الى حرب مع ايران في المنطقه وايضا
عدم استهداف تلك الجماعات التي تعتبرها
واشنطن مواليه يران بشكل كبير بحيث لا
يترك لها خيارا سوى الرد
والانتقام مما سيؤدي الى حرقه مفرغه من
الرد والرد الاخر لكن في نفس الوقت تريد
لتلك الهجمات
امريكيه التي نفذت الاولى الساعه الاولى
من هذا الصباح وتعهدت بان هناك المزيد ان
تثني تلك الجماعات على المزيد من الهجمات
سواء ضد القواعد الامريكيه في سوريا
والعراق او في البحر الاحمر هناك الجبهه
السياسيه التي لا تقل اهميه وخطوره ودقه
في حسابه الرئيس بايدن وحملته
الانتخابيه لانه لا يريد ان يوصف بالرئيس
الضعيف في مجال الامن القومي ضد جماعه
تقتل الجنود الامريكيين وهي ربما من اكثر
التهم تكلفه سياسيا في عام انتخابي شكرا
لكم محمد في واشنطن وسامر في
بغداد